merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur il s'appelait
Thomas il avait 16 ans il a été tué le
lundi 19 novembre avant tout je voudrais
ici lui rendre hommage saluer sa mémoire
dire ma solidarité à ses proches sa
famille et tous les blessés l'extrême
droite a instrumentalisé son maître des
expéditions vengeresses ont été lancées
à roman sur iser à Lyon à grenobble et à
Rennes un seul a été franchi
qu'avez-vous faire pour protéger nos
concitoyens de ces bandes néonazis qui
menacent qui agressent qui terrorisent
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
l'heure est grave quelle question posé
quel mot utiliser quel fait décrire pour
enfin vous faire réagir faut-il vous
rappeler les croix gamé tagué sur les
murs de nos villes la profanation des
tombes juives et musulmanes les
ratonnades et les meurtres racistes
monsieur le ministre nous vous allettons
depuis des mois sur ces ministres privés
que font les services de renseignement
expliquez-nous comment les agresseurs de
roman sur iser ont-il eu accès à la
liste des suspects les
judiciaire ne suffise pas ferme les
locaux fascistes arrêtez de sermer la
confusion l'extrême droite est
antisémite islamophobe et raciste pour
nous les choses sont claires si eux la
République doit être fracturée pour nous
elle doit rester unie je vais finir par
un message très fort surtout pour les
jeunes nos origines sont une une
richesse tenons notre ligne si eux il
divisent merci madame la
députée merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Gérald armanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
[Applaudissements]
outremires merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée je pense avoir répondu à
votre collègue du groupe communiste pour
dire qu'effectivement et vous avez
parfaitement raison il faut condamner
ces milices d'extrême droite d'ultra
droite qui terrorisent et qui veulent à
la place de l'État à la place des
policiers des gendarmes dont nous
remercions le courage lutter contre ce
qu'il pensent être le grand remplacement
attaqué des noirs des Arabes par leur
couleurs de peau et non pas acceptant
l'idée que l'autorité de l'État
l'égalité républicaine c'est pouvoir
arrêtter interpellé par la police de la
République selon des lois votées par le
Parlement les personnes pour ce qu'ils
font et non pas pour ce qu'ils sont vous
avez parfaitement raison et c'est pour
cela que je voudrais en premier lieu
plutôt plutôt que de les mettre en cause
madame la députée remercier les services
de renseignement qui ont déjoué 13
attentats de l'ultra droite et d'extrême
droite en France les remercier à Roman
szer d'avoir permis en effet d'éviter un
scénario à l'irlandaise en mettant des
policiers qui ont pu interpell une
dizaine de personnes qui sont et qui ont
été présenté au service de Monsieur
gardesso et condamné quelques heures
après leurs interpellations à des Pernes
extrêmement fermes qui ont d'ailleurs
été critiqué mais qui sont l'honneur de
la justice de notre pays monsieurard des
saut et vous dire madame la députée que
oui nous promettons les dis solutions
comme on l'a fait sur Génération
identitaire comme on l'a fait sur une
dizaines d'associations et de
groupuscules d'extrême droite mais je
regrette que vous nous ayez pas été
accompagné sur cette question puisque
votre groupe a voté contre la loi
séparatisme qui nous permet de dissoudre
l'association
fascistes merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre